Hoss Gomez my name is 45 welcome back to
dream boy where we got a date today
could it be Liam could it be same could
be Harry could be now could it be Louis
ha
am I kidding no one wants to date Louis
what's up crazy mofo marry me now no
thank you
god damn it it's so hard to play it cool
as a fangirl I understand the struggle
asking Foley on Twitter I don't trip a
lot me [ __ ] I will trip oh hi Marcia oh
hi Louise today is a great day isn't it
I just received some great news today
really what is it hon do a football team
football team
cool yeah you'll do well on the team how
nervous I hope I don't disappoint them
do you want to play football with me
what I'm a good why are we in Japan
anyway what the [ __ ] this hurt like why
the [ __ ] would I want to find God guess
I'll waste time with you soccer
challenge play who the [ __ ] is that is
that supposed to be him catch the ball
well what is this [ __ ] got your badge
catch I call it luck you caught your
balls like a poker bowl side you want to
play football yes standing the goal
while I [ __ ] try hard my ass off
thanks Luis stop stop low weights blow
it thanks for playing with me best date
of my goddamn life
Oh Oh Louise got the shoot balls at me
my favourite date what the [ __ ] is this
One Direction member louis thompson has
been injured in the charity football
match
it was tackled by a pro player gabrielle
Ashbourne a cobbler in the said game I
will get you Gabriel ass blown ah ha
fangirls rice upon a brutally murdering
Ashton got blood oh my god what should i
do I should show him my boobs or
something Louis
he seems fine he's wearing a little
thingy I saw what happened I hate
whoever did you stereo hahaha no it's
all part of the game it's not his fault
here when other people should not hate
him he didn't do it on purpose
well anyway I have to rest now [ __ ] off
I was great I'm glad we did that
good yes Nile Horace follow me on
Twitter
yes we are now good friends good what is
your birthday when it's my birthday
it's September I don't give a [ __ ] I
would say wrong okay I'm sorry
as always I'm just gonna go I'm just
gonna go now
let's talk to Harry do you like me he
doesn't even know who we are
I'll think about it but yeah I like you
Harry likes huh who the hell are you can
I take a picture with you get away from
what is this don't play with my emotions
I'm not when it's my birthday um febri
first I got it yay what you're out of
the hospital already hi there how are
you Luis good okay
Eiffel II football with him I visit the
hospital but he won't follow me on
Twitter
what a [ __ ] ass same is amazing oh
god oh god it's contagious Oh God
Ritchie same [ __ ] hosts and tricks
click on these d nuts and suck good
let's see if we can do something to
raise her Teen Choice Awards One
Direction is here today to perform their
sound best song ever
I think that's pretty self entitled to
name a song than if you ask me that was
it the Teen Choice Awards were clearly
just about one direction see you next
year who do you think did best
performance
well I think his aim was pretty amazing
oh god stop it um but I'll have to go
with Harry finally I just answered that
when is my break what is wrong with you
that's right what is my birthday shut up
shut your damn mouth god damn it what is
with these people and their birthdays
City Hall welcome everyone welcome
everyone today is the launch of one
Direction's fragrance our moment this
perfume has been specifically created
for Directioners to get erections the
smell of perfumes
was vast chastened by the balls Harris
favorite ingredient is Frank patty patty
Zane's favorite ingredient is jazz mine
Louis favorite ingredient is diarrhea
from a 40 year old virgin and Liam's
favorite ingredient is one giant it now
a favorite ingredient is the tears of
orphans if you want to watch it click
here
well what the [ __ ] am I doing with my
life would you like to buy I guess I
have to
yay 50 with everyone that's awesome
thank you you're welcome
whoa he actually gave me his number
hello
it's his Harry oh now we can gift them
oh my god the [ __ ]
like oh my god do you see this [ __ ]
what and he still don't like me
you remember my phone number you never
told me your number okay I guessed it
what the [ __ ] is is Luis calling me
you answered Luis call relationship
increased oh God
Luis can I talk to you sure do you like
my submit to your leg mates yet answer
me
do you like her so so what if I do
oh my god they're fighting over me
don't you have a girlfriend it's none of
your business
stop playing with her
I'm not what the hell is your problem
you already have a girlfriend you're
two-timing them that's right
Louise is two-timing me I think you
don't know anything
gotta piss me off chef Vigneron now
punches Louise punches back how will
this end
oh no Edie got to Christ because I was
two-timing [ __ ] fangirls don't two-time
it it's ugly
I'm so [ __ ] rich I'm really making
thousand grand a day easy I'm not only a
successful fangirl I'm also also very
successful businesswoman apparently oh
god I'm exhausted from fangirling it's
so hard but anyway I hope you bros enjoy
this episode if you did go ahead and hit
that like button and I will see you in
the next one that's always stay awesome
bros